can we just lay out some of the
competitors to SpaceX so much of what we
talked about is uh SpaceX specifically
because they're sort of pushing the
boundaries of what's possible in the
commercial space light but there's a lot
of like you said incredible work being
done for large companies and small
companies startups and so on uh so who
are the competitors to SpaceX
Ula United launch Alliance blue origin
as a Virgin uh it's a galactic orbit
orbit or the competitor virgin orbit uh
there's a rocket Labs electron rocket
that you mentioned
um there's the folks you covered Firefly
yep and uh what are we missing there's
the the Epic space launch system
from NASA I guess that is yeah
technically NASA but prime contractor
Boeing and Boeing
yeah North was the boosters yep
nice so like what uh what's what's
interesting to say to lay out the land
here that you're excited about just in
general I think if you aren't working on
a reusable some form of reusable vehicle
like physically working on it pen to
paper not Beyond pen to paper like
bending metal for a reusable vehicle
you're gone you're toast
I think we're well into that being the
only
provable you know Way Forward the only
way you're going to compete and survive
is a reusable rocket fully reusable
would be great but that's obviously
massively aspirational still
um but it will come
but to me
um
the the yeah the list you pretty much
had it right on the head uh there's
there's Astra was another orbital rocket
company
um they there's a lot of companies and I
think right now the
the ones that I personally really
believe in
um you know rocket lab is is awesome I
really think that they are
one of the few that I believe can
actually build a falcon 9 class rocket
uh like today with the with their
technology with their knowledge with
their Investments with their funding you
know like they've and they've proven
themselves there's very few they have
actually made it look easy I think
there's a lot of startups and a lot of
new rocket there's a too many launch
providers popping out of the woodwork
right now they won't all survive of
course I think realistically if you look
at like airplanes how many airplane you
know there's a handful of airplane
manufacturers there's not hundreds and
thousands of airplane manufacturers I
think it'll be a similar thing for space
flight I think we'll see we'll see you
know realistically in the terms of jumbo
adjusting passengers there's basically
two you know there's Airbus and there's
Boeing
um so I I think in the long run there'll
be two or three major players
I think they'll be you know 10
minor like as far as launch providers as
far as the ones actually leaving Earth
and getting into orbit I just don't
think there's a ton of room for
individuality really you know yeah I
would love to see it like a really
serious competitor uh to SpaceX in the
way that SpaceX does things I don't know
if your lake is quite
what I
is quite the right kind of competitive
let me let me say this Ula has all of
the potential but just operationally
they're you know they're you either
Lockheed Martin and Boeing's like love
child yeah but they're kind of set up in
a far too traditional manner where they
just really aren't given the opportunity
to uh innovate like a lot of these
startups are so rocket lab is a little
bit more of that nature what do you
think about sort of just blue origin in
general it's the origins ah man I
what blue origin has done with new
Shepard is amazing and people just lot
it because it's sub-orbital and it looks
very phallic it's
it's uh so I guess the meme matters also
it's modern day but it's sad because
people don't see what they are also
working on which is new Glenn you know I
see comments almost every day still of
like it doesn't matter because you know
they're they're working on Tiny it's
like no new Glenn is more powerful and
more capable than Falcon heavy new Glenn
is almost more of a competitor to not
quite as to Starship but it's almost in
that class it's a it's a heavy lift
launch vehicle it's huge it's crazy
it'll be nuts they're very actively
working on it you know I still think
we're three years away from it launching
but that's a very strong competitor in
the class of rockets that SpaceX is
currently making so SpaceX is currently
leading the way but that that it could
become a close race and what it's just I
will this for now we'll ignore SpaceX
and I'm just gonna talk about like I
think who's kind of coming around the
corner here who's here so let me just do
a quick overview I'm going to shoot
myself on the foot for getting some cool
people here and some some exciting
companies but relativity is one that if
you you should definitely get to MLS on
the show who is the CEO of Relativity
they're doing 3D printed Rockets
the ones that have the world's largest
3D printer they're getting really close
to their first orbital launch the cool
thing about them the reason that I think
they're exciting the reason that I I
think they have the potential is just
how quickly they can iterate I think 3D
printing a rocket is really dumb
I think iterating with 3D printing on a
rocket is brilliant because you can
literally change software and have like
very little you know upload a file and
have a new rocket like that's amazing so
in terms of long-term iterative process
if if we're really talking about like
hitting the ground running and and just
seeing where the the evolution takes you
I think that's about as good as you can
get you know I think what SpaceX is
doing at Starbase just physically
bending cheap steel is probably also a
very valid solution
all right so I really think and they
have the engineering jobs I think
they've got some amazing people there
um again rocket lab I adore what they
work on and you know like every everyone
there's a caveat here that everything
takes longer anything any company tells
you it's two or three times longer just
period rocket lab's no different
um but I really they're they're working
on a neutron rocket that's going to be
um like I think eight thousand to
fifteen thousand kilograms to low earth
orbit like it's a good medium class
rocket will compete right along with
Falcon 9 hopefully by the way Neutron
would be its name right yeah so that's
like kind of neutron it's not some kind
of fascinating new physics breakthrough
where they're using neutrons no no but
they are using they're also using liquid
methane and liquid oxygen
um I just think it's a really it's a
seems like a great rocket and assuming
they can actually get it flying in two
or three years I think they're gonna be
it's here to stay you know
um I I'd be remiss right now I'm editing
a video from an interview with Stoke
Aerospace out in in Kent Washington
um it's just one of these companies that
they have a long ways to go like they're
still in the very they're they're behind
the curve frankly in in terms of launch
Vehicles right now because like I said
there's so many coming out of the
woodwork but the idea they're working on
their solution to a fully reusable
rocket is amazing one of the coolest
Concepts I've ever seen are you going to
cover in the video yeah yeah that'll be
hopefully coming out the next depending
on what the schedule like is down there
I'm work I'm actively editing that as we
speak and it is
so cool I mean it is like it's it's
genius and um if they can actually get
it to work I can see them merging I can
for sure see someone potentially like I
perfectly in a perfect world they merge
with rocket lab they uh Stoke develops
the upper stage and maybe even the
engines they are the two guys the the
CEO the co-founders of that company
um have they are engine like propulsion
engineer magnificence they have they
used to they both have worked at Blue
they developed engines in a hurry there
and then left blue and it felt like it
was getting too slow for them and now
they are I mean these these guys fired a
15 chambered rocket engine instead of
four from the Soviet we're talking 15
Chambers single turbo pump
uh 70 times in the month of October wow
wow that's impressive oh and that's like
that was on average you know if you
think about like days off time off you
know Parts changing yes over twice a day
on average of a hydrolux engine that's
insane so I I love them and I hope the
best for them uh but they're also
topical right now they're top of my head
so uh what about Firefly what I like
about Firefly they've already got kind
of a traditional Aerospace backing
they're starting to Buddy up a lot with
Northrop grumman's they're going to be
building the booster stage for Antares
which is currently flying only out of
Wallops Virginia and is one of the only
other commercial providers for the
International Space Station and Northrop
Grumman is very traditional Aerospace
company you know like lots of solid
rocket boosters and they've purchased
ironically their their current Antares
is reliant on Russian engines and
Ukrainian boosters two things that I
don't think are going to be able to get
your hands on too much anymore so yes
they're looking to uh um some U.S
propulsion and stages so they actually
are partnering with uh with firefly and
their new Antares rocket will be a first
stage built entirely by Firefly so I'm
excited that Firefly already has the
propulsion technology
um and they actually developed
ironically their tap off cycle engine
was developed uh in partnership with
Ukraine with Ukrainian Engineers uh who
developed the the whole turbo pump
system so it's like it's this cool
meddling of of these worlds
um their former CEO Tom marcusic was all
like I have an interview with him and
he's anyone that can just
spout nuances and facts I just love I
just soaked that guy's information up as
best I could because he is brilliant
literally a doctor a rocket doctor you
know it's so yeah I mean that's what
like you said the fascinating thing
about these folks they're they're legit
they're they're such great Engineers
that people that bring these Rockets to
life and then there's all the stuff that
we know and don't know about in uh in
China and other parts and other nations
that are putting stuff into orbit one of
the sad things also is like you know
with Lockheed and and Boeing
is uh
it's just military applications in
general there's so much technology
that's currently being developed that we
probably know nothing about yeah
and um yeah it makes me a little bit sad
of course
yeah but for several reasons one is that
the use of that technology is has really
much like it's not it's not that
inspired it's like a very military Focus
yes to kill someone it's to kill someone
yeah uh there's not even like a
aside application right and and the the
big one is that the secret it's it's
shroud and in secrecy as opposed to
being a source of inspiration yeah 100
but that's the way of the world like
what was that one plane that you covered
that was like we know nothing about oh
the X-37B the X-37B yeah orbited for
over 900 days and returned like yeah I
want to mess that thing up to I don't
know
frustrating we know when it launches
people you know amateurs track and no
they even will be like oh it changed
orbit you know it raised and lowered its
orbit blah blah we generally have just
almost no idea what it's doing up there
and it just saddens me because I want to
know and it's awesome it's a great
vehicle
War what is it good for